Bộng giờ bộng biết phút hôn ngày May 6, tăng chiến năm 2018,
tổng đại một một bộng chung tông tương tinh chỉ viết công an thành phố nhận được tin bảo sử ra trái tại Thôn và Giá,
Sát thường tính, thành phố Hàn Nội.
Ngay sau khi nhận tin, chúng tông tương tinh chỉ viết công an thành phố đã hình chương đường đồng gần năm 2020.
Chính sĩ thuật các đổi trở trở trở và cứu nạn cứu hộ khu vực số năm 2020,
2020, phòng cảnh sát phòng trái trở trở trở và cứu nạn cứu hộ,
có ngon thành phố Hàn Nội với bây giờ trở trở trái, một sét tại trở phương tinh trở dụng.
Công lực lượng cánh sát một một bà thành phố để hệ trở với hộ chiến quyền,
có ngon sát cùng vừa dân được phương tổ chức trở trái và cứu nạn cứu hộ.
Đồng chi thì tổ tương với định hoàn,
phó cuộc trở của cánh sát phòng trái trở trở trở trở và cứu nạn cứu hộ,
bộ công an và đồng chi thì tổ tương với hộng ki.
Phó giám đốc công ăn thành phố trở tiếp có mặt tại hệ trở trở trở trở trở trở trở và cứu nạn cứu hộ.
Đi điểm sê ra trái lần nhạc có vị cấu tạm khu thép,
mai tôn, cao khoảng năm mẹ với dịch sản khoảng chimê mấy mê của
có lưu thân nạn khình cấp,
có chính sử dựng trở phép trên đất nông việp tại sát thử viến.
Đi khoảng năm giờ 3 mê phó cùng ngày, đám trái được giấc thấp hoàn phản.
Có chính trở trái, lựng lượng chức nạn phát hiện bún nạn nhân tử vong và bản ra cho lực lượng ít dế.
Mọi giống công tác nhận tình, tổ chức trở trái, cứu nạn cứu hộ rất khình chương,
kiệt tời tinh nhiên vụ trái vẫn vây ra hộ quả năm tiếp.
Đi hàng triệt thải só trái xe ra ở thử dân đang ui,
mấy cảnh việc trong bị các phương tiệt,
tính bị trưa trái bán đầu quân ăn thình phụ khuyên cao các hộ ra định đến trong bị nè
hệ thống kính bảo báo trái sống tại gia đình.
Hịt, giả nước quân ăn thình phụ đang chỉ đạo các lực lượng chức nạn khình chương đều tra,
làm sói mình nhiên vụ trái để giải quyết theo quy định pháp lật.